[Music]
vandana joins us in washington d.c
vandana how can we help
hi yes on friday we closed on a house
and
because of this market we were very fast
to just buy it because we
had to
and i just regret it even when we had
like the three days hoa clause i wanted
out but my husband really wanted to just
go ahead and get it
until i just kind of did it so we
wouldn't fight and ever since then i've
regretted it and we closed on friday and
have cried every single day since then i
feel like we made a mistake
tell me what is the tell george and i
the specific things you're regretting
right now
well
i mean we had to move to my daughter to
go to school because
we live across the street it's like the
stupidest district
and we wanted to do it because she could
be in the better school
she could be with her friends and
everything
and
he has some special needs in this school
has
this for the school that for her to be
able to go to for middle school has more
of the programming that she needs so we
did it for that no i understand
but listen that's a good thing what are
you specifically regretting i just feel
like it's a little bit
i don't know i just feel like we made a
big mistake we're gonna have to spend so
much money fixing this house and it's
gonna be more of a mortgage
and you know i found out my husband took
out a heloc to pay for it and
i found out all these things financially
as we were doing it i wonder if i just
did it so we could i found out my
husband owned i had a 50 000 personal
loan that i didn't know about i thought
we had paid off all our debts besides
our student loans
i'm so sorry bandana it sounds like
there's there's some financial
infidelity on top of the weight of an
impulsive home purchase
so he here the heel off which
i learned about
as he was doing it and now that i've
learned more about hilock's and
listening to you i'm a little bit scared
because that's what we used to pay for
this house
and
you know
we paid off
we paid off the personal loan from the
heloc queue so we could close on this
house
and yeah now we can definitely it's not
that we can't afford this house now
because all the
debt is gone but i just i don't know
okay okay so the house sounds like we
robbed peter to pay paul here we just
got to move the debt around exactly
bandana george is going to walk you
through this but here's what i want okay
you need to just
focus right now on less emotion and
start plugging in some numbers for
george all right so i'm going to get us
started okay what's your household
income and then what is the mortgage
cost of you give us those two numbers
so our household income is 250 thousand
dollars before
taxes
before taxes fantastically
like 12
700 to 900 a month what's the mortgage
including the heloc so all that together
what is that
i don't know including the heloc how
about just the mortgage okay just the
mortgage
just the mortgage is about including
like hoa in taxes is about 4
500. okay so if i'm doing the math here
you're looking at
34 of your take-home pay
yeah is going into so now that's that's
higher than what i'd like it to be but
it's not killing you
like you said you guys can afford it
yeah i think a lot of the emotion is
coming from the fact that you're
learning a lot of things you didn't know
because your husband lied to you
yeah i think so yes you did impulsively
get into this house but that's not the
bigger issue here the bigger issue is
that you and your spouse need to get on
the same page and go we're married there
are no lies in this relationship
and so i think that's going to be your
a1 is not fixing the house problem it's
fixing the relationship problem and that
might look like counseling that might
look like going through financial peace
university together on top of that
but we got to get to the root of why he
hid these things from you
i think he was just the same
because before he had credit card debt
and i sold my condo and literally i gave
him every single dollar out of my condo
i was a teacher i quit working
after
during the pandemic so i could
homeschool my child and i haven't wanted
to go back because for the few months i
did
i did teach
i was so stressed out and i went back
for a little bit this year and my
anxiety went up i wasn't sleeping
nothing and that's like i just had to
put he put on anxiety medicine just
taking these days is just so difficult
and it just couldn't deal with
everything and then
you know
i or i thought we were out of debt i
thought we were completely out of debt
because when i found out about the
credit cards i i had a condo that i had
oh my goodness
i'm so sorry vandana we are so so very
sorry but as george said i want you to
walk away from this to say hey you and
your hubs just see you on the same page
if you had some shame
take the shame away and just say hey can
we get on the same page i'm feeling a
tremendous amount of anxiety and fear
over this you guys know how to pay debt
off start attacking it just like you
were starting all over again you guys
can get there house isn't gonna fall in
on itself it's gonna be okay but you
guys have got to get on the same page
relationally
so that you can get on the same page
financially